طبعا نحن هنا في مدينه اصلاحيه في غاز
عنتاب وهي اكثر المناطق تضررا في هذه
الولايه تقريبا نصف المباني هنا دمرت
بالكامل والنصف الاخر
الدمار اتى الدمار الجزئي اتى على غالبيه
النصف الثاني تقريبا نتحدث عن 80% من
مباني هذه المدينه غير صالحه للسكن 50%
دمر بالكامل و30% متصدع وقايل للهبوط كما
في هذا الحي الذي نشاهده فارغا تماما حتى
ان اليات الانقاذ لا استطيع يعني لا ادري
اذا كانت الصوره قد ترصد المشهد الاليات
توقفت عن العمل لبعض الوقت فرق الانقاذ
توقفت عن العمل لبعض الوقت طبعا هنا
الكهرباء مقطوعه بالكامل عن هذه المدينه
هذا الحي بالكامل هو على الارض لا يوجد اي
بناء صمد حتى هذا البناء الذي في المنتصف
هو غير للسكن سيتم هدمه قريبا بعد
الانتهاء من رفع الانقاض طبعا نتحدث طب
هذا عن مدينه تقريبا بالكامل منكوبه لا
يوجد فيها
مباني صالحه للسكن اكثر من 20% من
عدد المباني الاصليه لذلك هذا المشهد هنا
في هذا الحي يلخص
مشهد المدينه بالكامل طبعا لا شك ان
عمليات رفع الانقاض كانت مستمره الى ما
قبل ساعات قليله او الى ما قبل وقت قصير
في هذه المدينه يوم امس تم انتشال شخصين
كانوا على قيد الحياه في هذا الموقع الذي
كنا فيه ايضا صباح يوم امس او ظهره يوم
امس كان الحديث عن وجود خمسه اشخاص ما
زالوا عالقين تحت الانقاض وكانت فرق
الانقاذ تحاول اخر
من تحت الانقاض لكن لم يكن لم يكنوا
متاكدين فيما اذا كانوا على قيد الحياه لم
تصلهم اشارات بوجود اشخاص ناجين او ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه طبعا عمليات البحث
والانقاذ ما تزال مستمره هنا في
اصلاحيه الان لم نشاهد يعني من وصولنا الى
المدينه فجر اليوم الاليات تعمل كل اليات
هنا خلف الكاميرا تقريبا متوقفه هناك بعض
هناك
هناك بعض الاليات في الطرف الاخر لكنها
تعمل على ازاله الانقاض فقط
من مناطق تم الانتهاء من عمليات الانقاذ
في هذه العموم نتحدث عن مدينه منكوبه هي
جزء من ما قالت عنه الحكومه دمار على اكثر
من 500 كيلو متر
جنوب تركيا وايضا زلزال شعر به
شعر به من
الف كيلو متر